I I had massive insecurities about my
father's approval he said every decision
that I had made was not a good decision
after I decided to Veer off the path of
the job and it was only when I had
literally made more money than he'd ever
made in his entire life that he said you
know you're going to want to hear this
and he was like I'm sorry for saying
that you shouldn't have done this he's
like but for the record if it had been
30 years ago when I was coming up I
would have been right and I remember
thinking to myself if I cared about your
opinion I wouldn't have done it I'd
break the sting of your approval when I
was literally on my balcony thinking
about myself in my Consulting career
well if the alternative is death then I
can at least disappoint my father and
that's why you probably often hear me
measure a lot of decisions against death
because it helps me gain perspective on
what is important